Every time the
browser connects to a server
to make a request, it has to
go through the TCP handshake
process.
This three-way handshake
is very time consuming.
To counteract the cost
of these handshakes,
HTTP/1.1 introduced the
concept of keep-alive.
If the client sets the
connection keep-alive header,
the server will not
close the connection
after successfully
delivering the response,
but allows the client to
reuse the already established
connection for
additional requests.
Keep in mind though that
you still can send requests
before the response
for the last request
has been fully transferred.
All in all, this forces
web developers to keep
the number of additional
resources as low
as possible, making
the best possible use
of their six connections.
This is why JavaScript
and CSS files are commonly
concatenated into bundles and
why images are put together
into sprites.
The bundles can be obtained
in just one request.